Avengers; Infinity War ended with the biggest
downer since The Empire Strikes Back, so it’s
no wonder that everyone’s trying to figure
out what’s going to happen when Thanos returns
to the screen in 2019.
From clues we’ve picked up from the comics
to hints that we’ve already seen, here are
our predictions for the possible outcomes
of Avengers 4.
Spoiler warning: we’re going to be talking
a lot about the end of Infinity War.
The New Black Panther
The most shocking part of Infinity War came
when Thanos snapped his fingers and killed
half the universe, and it only got more surprising
when it turned out that half included heroes
like Spider-Man, Bucky, Doctor Strange, and
the Black Panther.
Since there are about 1.3 billion reasons
and counting to keep that last guy around,
we’re guessing that most of those deaths
are probably going to be undone by the end
of Avengers 4.
"As you can see, I am not dead."
Even if it’s just for now, though, T’Challa’s
death leads to the most obvious idea for the
next one: Shuri becoming the new Black Panther.
With the heart-shaped herbs gone at the end
of Black Panther, Shuri would be able to use
her expertise with technology to step into
the role.
We've even seen her in action, fighting with
panther-shaped energy gauntlets.
All she needs is the costume.
The other strong possibility would be that
Nakia takes over instead, but Shuri's the
one who becomes Black Panther in the comics
when T’Challa is incapacitated.
With Marvel Studios' track record of using
elements from stories like Winter Soldier
and Infinity Gauntlet as road maps, that seems
like one they'd want to stick with.
King of the Dead
If Shuri does become the Black Panther, that
leaves us with the question of what could
happen with T’Challa.
We’re pretty sure he’s going to come back
to life somehow, but something in the comics
gives another possibility: he might just become
the King of the Dead.
In the comics, T’Challa found himself conflicted
after Shuri took over as the leader of Wakanda.
He wanted to be Black Panther again, but he
doesn't want to interfere with Shuri’s reign.
Obviously, he solves this problem by going
to the secret necropolis under the Golden
City so that he can talk to Bast, the cat
goddess.
You know, pretty standard cat stuff.
To give him a new purpose, she made him King
of the Dead, with all the strength and wisdom
of every Black Panther before him.
Who better to lead a team of superheroes back
to the land of the living than him?
Asgard Reborn
Infinity War’s shocks aren’t limited to
the end of the movie.
Right at the beginning, we find out that Thanos
and the Black Order killed all of the Asgardian
refugees that Thor worked so hard to save
in Ragnarok.
That might not be the end of Asgard, though.
In the comics, Ragnarok isn't the end of the
world, it's the end of a cycle.
As gods, Thor and the other Asgardians are
creatures of mythology — they live, die,
and are reborn into new forms, eternally bound
by their nature.
If we're following that logic, then the next
major quest for a Thor who's more powerful
than ever could be the rebuilding of Asgard
by tracking down the reborn souls of the other
gods — including an all-new, all-different
Loki.
The return of Korg, Miek, and Valkyrie
They couldn’t really kill the three best
new movie characters of 2017 offscreen between
movies, could they?
Until proven otherwise, let’s just assume
that Korg, Miek, and Valkyrie weren't on the
refugee ship for some reason.
Maybe they were out scouting for groceries,
or fighting the Skrulls.
Anything to get them back for next time.
Seriously: If Happy Hogan can be in like six
of these movies, then Valkyrie needs to be
in at least ten.
Tony Stark, R.I.P.
A lot of moviegoers predicted that we’d
be bidding a fond farewell Robert Downey Jr.
in Infinity War.
That didn’t happen this time, but it may
have been set up for Avengers 4.
Doctor Strange traded Thanos the Time Stone
in exchange for sparing Tony Stark's life.
That's surprising, first because Strange swore
an oath to protect it, and second because
he did it knowing that if Thanos got the stones,
he was going to kill half the galaxy anyway.
Even if Strange and Stark were BFFs and not
just dudes who didn't actually seem to like
each other, there's no way anyone should trade
Iron Man's life for uncountable trillions.
Unless…
Shortly before that scene is the one where
Strange uses the time stone to take a peek
at 14 million alternate outcomes, and says
that the good guys only win in one.
Given the bargain he makes, you have to assume
that the one reality where Thanos is defeated
has to be one where Tony Stark lives long
enough to do something to turn the tide.
We’re betting it’s a heroic sacrifice
that's been building for 11 years.
The All-New Iron Man
Tony Stark might be on the way out, but Iron
Man could stick around.
It's just going to be Jim Rhodes under the
helmet instead.
Like Shuri, this one follows the precedent
set in the comics.
Before he was War Machine, Rhodey was Iron
Man from 1983 to 1985.
It also seems like a logical continuation
of the story.
He's the only one besides Tony to fight in
the Iron Man armor, and the big airport battle
in Civil War left him injured, needing Stark's
tech to walk.
That puts him in a very similar position to
the way Tony was back in his early comics
appearances, when he needed his armor to keep
his heart beating.
If Rhodey does take over, that provides proof-of-concept
for the idea that the MCU can continue after
the departure of big-name actors, something
that was already done on a small scale when
Don Cheadle took over the role of Rhodey from
Terrence Howard.
"Next time, baby."
Keep waiting for Adam Warlock
Adam Warlock is a huge part of the original
Infinity Gauntlet story.
While his role for the most part is limited
to standing around in space watching the big
battle go down, he actually winds up in possession
of the Gauntlet itself at the end.
Between that and his imminent arrival being
teased in the post-credits scene of Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2, it might have been surprising
that he didn’t make an appearance in Infinity
War.
He’s even the focal point of the comic book
crossover that gave the movie its name.
If you’re thinking they might have saved
him for the sequel, though, it doesn’t seem
likely.
One of the few movies to have actually been
announced for the next phase of Marvel movies
was Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3.
With Adam being set up as Ayesha’s genetically
engineered instrument of revenge, it’s way
more likely that he’ll show up there.
That leaves the role open for a space-faring
hero who can explain galactic conflicts, and
it seems pretty obvious that it’s going
to go to Captain Marvel, who was summoned
at the end of Infinity War by Nick Fury’s
cosmic beeper.
That makes sense structurally, since Captain
Marvel and Ant-Man and the Wasp are the only
MCU movies coming out between Infinity War
and Avengers 4.
As much as we like Scott Lang, he’s not
the guy who’s going to be getting everyone
up to speed on the Kree/Skrull War.
Carol Danvers, on the other hand, has experience
battling against and wielding exactly the
kind of cosmic power that the heroes are going
to need to beat Thanos once and for all.
That leaves the Guardians free to fly back
into their own movie, and the only question
left is whether they’ll fight Adam Warlock
or the Magus, who is Adam Warlock’s evil
self from an alternate future.
Comic books can be pretty complicated.
Capwolf at last
We’ll admit that this one’s pretty unlikely,
but if Infinity War has proven anything, it's
that the Marvel movies can do anything and
make a billion dollars.
They've spent ten full years and 19 movies
getting to that point, but they just put out
a movie about a giant purple man trying to
get his hands on magic space rocks, featuring
characters like Proxima Midnight and the Collector,
and a major plot point was that a space dwarf
made a magic hammer out of a talking tree.
We’re not complaining, but you have to admit
that stuff’s pretty weird.
Clearly, there’s nothing stopping them from
doing a movie where Captain America becomes
a super-powered werewolf and delivers an inspirational
speech to a bunch of other werewolves.
It might even make sense from a movie-making
standpoint.
If Chris Evans really does want to scale back
his acting work and devote his time to remodeling
his house, then why not replace him with a
CGI wolfman with an indestructible shield?
It would definitely be a weird direction to
lift from the comics, but they already did
the part where Thanos starts turning people
into cubes.
There’s no way a wolf is any weirder than
that.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!